writer card romantic one  brains to be the best the bill  Shakespeare Roman coin they tell me that  you divorce Karen right here you like to  watch bum fights let make me feel better  somehow wrench  I cut a tendon you can't ride with the  other fingers I hate optimistic people  they sought me out with her upbeat  attitude are you real the state of  California will establish a new holiday  girlfriend's day we're going to hold a  contest to see who can write the most  romantic card if you had it then you can  get it back I need you to write a card a  romance card great one I mean just good  money here for you oh did this in I  can't can't kill himself  I found in 12 in a row is for what  happened for you I think it has  something to it the coffin it kills  people over to holla who are you working  for this just keeps getting weirder  it wasn't worth making getting paper cut  how about to peel oh we go ahead  ah-ah-ah  that's yet I'm looking write me a card  and tell  Oh  you